All right, so now we're in a good position to define the set p of polynomial time decidable problems.
So this is a set, this includes a bunch of problems, a problem is in the set if there's an algorithm
for that problem such as that when inputs size n, the running time for solving that problem
is in big O then to the k for some constant k.
So there has to be some kind of polynomial upper bound of an algorithm
to solve that problem for the problem to be in p.
This k--this constant k is allowed to vary with the class of the problem, but any particular instance
still needs to be solved and into the k.
So it's nÂ˛--they're at the end of the fifth--whatever it happens to be.
And just in case it's not obvious, running times like Î˜ of logn are in big O nk for some k.
In this case, k=1 suffices.
The class p is often contrasted with the class np that I'm going to define next.